Đó thế giới, bệnh vị tâm ai lập kí lục vượt móc 1 ca. Thay khó vực tạp mằng siêu rebot AI. Người bệnh thóc
Mì câu tàn phép, chỉ vì chỉ từ 1 ca. Mí lâm sự, có á sục bởi vì tế, háng sản xuất rebot
18 tây dời khu dây xô về công bố chút mừng và đánh giá cao thình tích của bệnh vị đã qua
tâm ai sau khi bệnh vị tình vượt móc 1 ca. Thay khó vực tạp mằng rebot AI kí lối choa thế hệ mới,
cộp móc này được tý lập chỉ khoảng 1 cao khi tâm ai lập hát chích với bà chính nghiệnh
có tế xuất sắp về phố thuật thay khó bằng rebot kiểu viết choa tích hợp AI. Ông trời gong diên,
giá đốc từ hại khúc tế, háng rebot cuu dây xô, đánh giá tôi bộ đặt hơn 1 ca.
Mộ và tỷ lệ tình công một trong phần trong của bệnh vị tâm ai nục tóc đậu thế giới.
Mộ chội xô với kí khoảng bán đầu được vi nhận tại các bệnh vị lớn ở châu Âu,
hàn quốc, ở nộ, thông vừa, tại nhiều cơ sở ý tế của tế, phải mất sau đến 12 tháng để đặt được
sống một trong ca. Phố thuật robot sau việc lửa trọn bệnh nhân. Đạo thạo như lực làm chù công nghệ và các kí thật linh quan,
kể thuốc ưu tụi tình sĩ bác si trời khó hài lê văn tấn, giá nóc chung tâm trình thư chính nghiệnh.
Kể thống bệnh vị đa khóa tâm ai n thể phố chính nghiệnh. Chào biết phần lớn trong hơn một trong ca. thay khó bằng rebot AI thì hệ mối được ưu tiên chỉ định cho những ca bệnh phút tạm.
Bộ rất khó hoặc không thể thực hiện tình công và an toàn cao bằng các kí thuật chừng thống hay các rebot thì hệ của
như người bệnh đối mặt với câu tình phép sò bình sạch khóp nặng phải tử sương, có giúp phần mềm dính khóp,
lệ trục chi, ló sương nặng, mắt nhiều bệnh định họ có này phía sò gái sương cạnh theo. Phố thuật bối
robot thì hệ mối đã giúp đều sị thình công ngoại mong đợi, hết đau khó phục khả năng đi lại.
Bình như là trường hợp của ông Hau, bệnh miếng tuổi, là người thử một trong thay khó của bằng rebot AI kiểu viết cho tại mình viện tâm ai nc.
Ông bị thay khó khó của dài đoạn của ý, đo đứng không thể đi lại. Tình sĩ bác xí trường khó hay li vàn tấn chỉ định
khó của bằng rebot TV choi, phần mềm AI giúp lập kế hoa chức mục, định vị cắt sương và hỗ trợ đặt khó chừng
rất từ miếm emet. Băng ai xong mục, ông Hau sẽ bị đi lại nhận, chung mình một cơ thể khó bằng
robot AI khoảng tiện chỉ khoảng sống mới đến chiếm với phút với chiếp vi trận hoa khoảng từ 1850.
Chỉ bằng khoảng một phần bối sò với các nắc sự dụng cùng lại rebot và được hưởng nhiều hạm một bà hiểm i tế theo
bánh nhân ít mất mấu, giản đau việc qua, có thể tập phục hồi chức năng sống và đến rất hay lòng với kế hoa điều gì.
Khó viên tạo xong mủ mạng lại cần giá tự nhiên, người bệnh đi lại thời mái ít có cần giá phục biểu.